it's the social media roundup here's
what your favorite celebs like Chrissy
Teigen Chris Hemsworth and Adele have
been up to lots of baby fever hitting
the Internet Olympic gold medalist Bode
Miller has welcomed his fourth child he
shared this revealing photo of his wife
Morgan and their newborn flipping outs
Jeff Lewis also sharing a sweet photo of
his new baby with the funny caption day
12 and she's still alive bachelorette
star Ashley Hubbard shared this adorable
photo of her baby girl essex reese
rosenbaum chrissy teigen and john legend
are also enjoying family time watching
the LA sunset with daughter Luna but
baby fever isn't the only current craze
celebs from beyonce to Hillary Clinton
are taking on the mannequin challenge
here's Adele's Western take of the viral
sensation
in a not so surprising news chris
hemsworth beach bod is still intact
here's the australian hunk hitting the
waves
hayden Panettiere is also going for a
dip but she's swimming in the Dead Sea
she called the experience one of the
most incredible things as she's ever
done
you